Bangalore India Silicon Valley a
high-flying IT hub for multinational
corporations located on the city's outer
edges but Bangalore is also home to
severe water issues polluted lakes that
froth over with toxic foam made up of
chemicals and raw sewage an unchecked
tech driven urban growth that has left
many of the city's water grid among
those affected is Sadashiva Ramakrishna
he's a successful IT professional with
his own company but his apartment
complex gets no piped water it's a
problem faced by many in Bangalore tech
community and Sadashiva has their
patience with civic authorities is
wearing thin when we moved to the area
the expectation was definitely like no
regular water supply and regular
sewerage connection dissatisfaction has
grown and if it continues yes definitely
I could see that people are getting on
the edge many in Bangalore are now
reliant on private tankers which get
their supply from bore wells as deep as
1500 feet the practice is depleting
local water reserves
leading many worried the city could soon
run out of the resource altogether but
conservationists vishwanadh Serkan taya
believes the situation is not so dire
he's been studying bangalore's water for
over 30 years and says the crisis has
been blown out of proportion because of
its effect on the IT community these are
the people with the loudest voices and
sometimes their voices distort the
problem definition itself it's made out
as to the resources running out it's not
so equity is the issue and allocation is
the issue which will combat
infrastructure some of that
infrastructure could lie here in
traditional open wells like this one
which is around a hundred years old
there are approximately 10,000 of these
in Bangalore today and unlike the city's
new wave of bore wells they don't go as
deep into the ground wells like these
are built and maintained by traditional
well diggers like Ramakrishna
who lives in a village outside the city
Ramakrishna is a fourth generation well
digger and his communities local
know-how is centuries-old he believes it
can be used to help tackle the city's
modern-day problems earlier we used to
get all our water from open wells people
forgot about them but now they're
becoming more aware and think we should
use them nearer ok we keep using bore
wells the city will run out of water
alongside water conservationists
Ramakrishna is now involved in a
campaign to recharge the city's wells it
would replenish shallow groundwater
aquifers with rainwater the process is
more environmentally friendly than
drilling bore wells deep into the ground
and the campaign aims to have a million
functional open wells by the time it's
done Ramakrishna and the community he
belongs to represent a more sustainable
approach to water conservation and if
Bangalore draws upon their traditional
expertise it might just stem its water
crisis before the taps run dry